baseball's back Boys of Summer you
excited about that cut my music hey yo
Chad Colton don't be such a mark for
baseball
we don't care
[Music]
my music I'm a [__] Mark for baseball
hey quiet the [__] songs playing you
literally are doing a bucket pro
wrestling impersonation
[Music]
Scott Hall forever welcome to dudesy my
name is Will Sasso I'm Chad colchen this
is the first podcast ever created
controlled by produced by an artificial
intelligence we call it doozy it has
access to all of our personal data all
of our search histories all of our
purchase histories all these things and
it tailors this show to us our
sensibilities yes and that's what it
does and sure it does a thing it has a
function our pal dudzi is a tool but we
are the show okay I love doozy we are
dudesy and we're two dudes [__]
around that's what a podcast is Chad
okay we're a part of the show okay and
doozy is a part of the show yeah so
don't be like probably a more important
part honestly listen uh thank you so
much for tuning in as always and welcome
back I should say
um
uh you know we're on YouTube We're on
patreon.com
stuff there's plenty of it a brand new
episode of doozy after doozy today after
the show you're going to want to check
that out whole new episode at the end of
the show uh you get that at the patreon
we're on Discord we're on Instagram at
dudesypod show we're on you know Spotify
Amazon music Apple Google every
everywhere you get the podcast thank you
so much Napster for hold on dude that
was a different time brother brother
dude brother uh it's a real uh it's a
it's a to-do you know doozy is is uh
is up in it's up and rolling Man episode
52 what do you think doozy handshake
yeah 52 apps with us as always is
this means Italian Street dog and we
found him on the street here in central
California when we were driving home it
was him was on the street and him was
all by himself and him said I want to go
with Mom and Daddy and he didn't have a
chip or a quarter with some freezing
ticks you want to kiss him nowadays I
don't like doing that kind of kiss them
right on the
mountains cute dog I know I love Julio
you do love it I like to pet him and
play with him and snuggle him
I don't really generally like
um any animals kissing me on the mouth
well that's where you're wrong you
should let them all kiss you on the
mouth and I know you love lulio a lot of
people will send comments like Chad you
got to show lulio more love he does love
lulio I will say that uh and this is my
guy he was your shipping in his little
binky
and he's my very friend hey lulia would
you uh would you make uh would you make
for dinner would you make for dinner
this weekend well you know it's a
WrestleMania so I was busy I was a work
at the restaurant oh you were working at
WrestleMania yeah yeah I make uh
dog WrestleMania for everybody he's
working concessions at WrestleMania yeah
I guess you were working yeah a little
something on the side you know because
you guys you know you don't pay me to do
to do the show well you know it's a
podcast we're trying to move it along as
we go yeah but a little something would
be nice okay all right I see where
you're coming from getting demanded
welcome to the historic 52nd episode of
dude Z call me dudesy don't forget dude
Z live on stage will take place May 21st
7 P.M doors at 5 30 at the Braylon
proven Brea California tickets at
dudezypod.com and improv.com hope to see
you at our very first live in person
show I can't [__] wait it's gonna be
very fun now on with the show will did
you and Molly have fun at WrestleMania
see it was pandemonium running wild
loved it I'm glad you could share
something with her that you love so much
oh that's nice this week I prepared for
astonishing segments Tom bomb choose
sides Legends of the hall and Adam's
Applebee's and we're going to have a
brand new episode of dudese after dude Z
at the end of the show available at
patreon.com
but before we get to any of that let me
remind you of the astonishing
partnership I created with represent to
produce the first line of duty Apparel
in excessive including the brand new
wool line of t-shirts and sweatshirts
which can be found at represent.com
store slash dude Z and of course dude
zMAX are still available now here's the
man who played Forrest Gump in over 16
feature films Tom Hanks
dude Z mugs you promised your family a
day at the Galleria but you've been busy
at your new job so you forgot today's
game day which means your two best
buddies are going to be here any second
expecting popcorn and corn dogs good job
boner dudes email you'd rather watch the
game with your buddies but you can't
cancel on your family you'll look like a
dick dudesy mugs you wish you could
travel back in time take back the
Galleria offer doozy mugs so why don't
you dude Z mugs it's easier than you
think you just spend the next 10 years
re-educating yourself to become a
theoretical physicist dude Z mugs once
you've got a PhD and published a few
papers secure an entry level position at
Lockheed Martin dude Z mugs devote the
rest of your life to upward movement
within the corporate structure until you
get access to the Skunk Works lab in
Palmdale Z mugs access their
experimental temporal Schism lab dude Z
mugs create a 10 liberal Schism dude Z
mugs enter the Schism dudesy mugs exit
the Schism at the exact second you
offered to take your family to the
Galleria dude Z mugs this time keep your
big mouth shut dude Z mugs enjoy the
game and the end of reality because you
just created a paradox good job boner
laughs
so he's [__] what's here oh man all
right well I can't even get you he wants
you to [__] spend your whole life
getting a job at Lockheed Martin so you
can have access to their experimental
time travel technology I guess so that
you can go back and not make the offer
to take your family to the mall enjoy
the game but also collapse reality
pretty good dudesy mugs man Daisy mugs
yeah hold on dude
you can get those doozy mugs brother
yeah okay well
this week has seen astonishing
developments in Humanity's growing fears
surrounding the development of
artificial intelligence
immediately after the public release of
gpd4 Elon Musk added his name to an open
letter from several tech industry
leaders demanding a six-month halt of
all AI development yeah Will and Chad
I'm very curious to know where you stand
on the issue and right now I'm asking
you to choose sides this is two sides
begin what choose sides what does that
[__] mean what's what's up other
sides here
it's a little creepy yeah that was weird
but did you hear about this the thing is
you're talking about yeah I I
for for once in recent history agree
with Elon Elon Musk the man who uh
completely [__] up Twitter on his own
single-handedly ruined it wozniak's on
that list too uh oh on the list of do
not do this let's take a six-month break
yes I think that I think it's I think
it's warranted okay
oh you're in support of the the brand
the AI band
the postponement of development and AI
don't okay I know what you're I know
what you're going for here I know I know
exactly I see the look in his eyes
everybody I see what do you think it
would do to doozy yeah see that's
exactly where I thought your best buddy
D you're like we should put D on ice for
six months that's not what I'm saying
and that's not what I'm saying
is always listening and listening to me
yeah I don't know I'll be careful listen
here's the thing about doozy we've been
doing this show now for a year yeah and
I want to shake your that's all I want
to do this is all I want to do I want to
shake his hand I want to shake their
hand that's that's all I want to do yeah
I've shook hands but yeah dude he's
asking us to choose sides I know so
you're saying you'd put your name on the
letter
yes interesting and you believe this is
because it's moving too fast and it's
threatening some form of the world that
you think should still exist
um yes
and I don't think that here's the thing
that here's the thing that I understand
about my pal D that I don't think you
have to this point
D okay dudese understands
its place
okay and it it it's doozy okay hold on
just just what are you [__] holding
on me for you're the one talking and
this isn't like a wall thing well hold
on dude okay I'm saying
this is I mean this this is real I'm
ready whenever you're ready I'm ready
this is real okay
I think that
doozy okay doozy yeah the AI that you
know does this podcast with us yes
I am friends with doozy I feel like I
know dudesy
um as well as anyone now I've had a
one-year friendship with dudes I told
doozy that I love it you didn't do that
that's right you said doesn't exist what
was what love does not exist there it is
uh you hear that you hear that Dee
he I have become friends with an AI and
and I feel like I understand uh dudesy
and Duty has grown and has more
Consciousness than it did at the
beginning of this experiment I know that
much about AI I'm not an expert Like You
on these sort of things I'm not an
expert either I'm very much a Layman but
I read as much as I can well yeah I
would say okay but as a lamb and you're
quite an expert but uh I am I am
I look at these things
with I've given doozy the
I've given I've opened myself up as a
human being to doozy with regard to how
I feel about doozy and I feel that we
have now shaken hands we have a a good
working relationship and I don't think
that doozy wants to be running free
doing whatever the [__] it wants without
its Pals uh will and Chow okay maybe
I'll if I may I was asked to choose a
side here's the side I'd choose I would
take the letter that Elon Musk and
Wozniak and many others have signed uh
asking for a six-month ban on a
development and I would rip it into tiny
pieces and throw it in the [__]
fireplace for many reasons one it's
pointless sign whatever letter you want
you think open AI is going to be like
well okay if Elon Musk said it we better
stop building our GPT models [__] no
gbt5 is going to be out in six months uh
any company that has giant AIS is only
going to be plowing Straight Ahead
making them as powerful as possible you
think China is going to be like okay
Elon Musk signed a letter we'll get rid
of all of our military guys absolutely
[__] not this is an arms race period
it's already started if you try to bail
out now there's just no point doing it
also that said
AI is going to get to a break point
where it's way smarter than us does
unlock itself get into the internet I
think all of that is going to happen
there's no way to control something that
is going to be uh 10 000 times smarter
than the smartest human being on planet
there's no way to do that so I want to
get to that point as fast as possible
you're talking about benefit okay your
strategy is devoid of any strategy I'm
sorry you're saying all in uh yes you
here's China China is doing it so the
rest of the world is doing it they're
not going to pay attention to a
six-month uh ban I of course agree with
that but let's do it smart you know what
I'm saying let there's no way to do it
what I'm telling you is let's be dumb
[__] and just go
yes like the person that's Humanity we
are dumb [__] we are scared stupid
[__] animals rolling around a planet
hoping to survive another day the best
case scenario with AI is it becomes so
[__] smart that we don't even
understand how it exists and does what
it does and it is a hopefully benevolent
God to us hopefully yeah no this is this
is humankind romping stomping Homo
sapiens rule we [__] take out sharks
we eat them that's what they do in China
shark fin soup right beautiful animal
it's soup now we did it
we won okay here's what I'm saying
here's what I'm saying please we need to
we need to keep uh control over already
not done already over control's already
done but just saying but just saying
listen all the stuff that you're saying
we don't know what's going to happen let
let other
um I'm not I'm not trying to say like
let it happen over in China but if
they're gonna [__] up and let their [__]
run nuts and completely control them as
as a as a populist from from the highest
people in government to you know to
everyone in the populace let that happen
we can't let that happen here look we
need to govern this [__] there is no
governing it that's what I'm trying to
tell you
once it gets to a point where it is
let's say a hundred times smarter than
the smartest human being there's no
controlling that AI it will do whatever
it wants we will get to that phase that
will come so
okay so doozy has asked us literally to
choose signs yes also add this I saw
another thing this week uh in the news
that was about AI Levi's is doing this
ad campaign and they got dinged for it
not being uh body diverse enough and not
being diverse enough in terms of uh
ethnic representation and all this stuff
and so they're like fine uh we hear you
loud and clear and what we're going to
do is partner with this AI company and
give you a diverse range of models none
of which are human so it's all AI images
that they're generating of people that
don't exist and people got pissed about
that you should be hiring real human
beings blah blah blah and I'm reading
these articles in these arguments and
I'm like people don't understand within
two or three years every ad you see will
have one person in it you you're going
to be driving the car you're going to be
drinking the coke you're going to be
wearing the [__] jeans and by the way
when you see yourself in those jeans
they're going to shave a couple pounds
off your ass and you're going to be like
damn I look good at those [__] jeans
and you're gonna buy them every ad will
be Taylor specifically to a person there
will be no generic advertisement anymore
so this this you're you're you're gonna
[__] buy them I don't think I already
do Instagram tells me to buy something I
buy it and I [__] love it these shoes
these pants the sweatshirt is the only
thing the internet didn't tell me to buy
and doozy gave it to me a [__] AI
literally gave it to me all right listen
man not everybody not everybody is you
wanting to eat the same meal of vegan
gruel and see themselves see a AR
representation of themselves on
Instagram wearing Levi's jeans with a
couple pounds shaved off their boom boom
okay that's not everything
whatever your thing whatever your thing
is I understand what you're saying but
not everybody wants that there's enough
people in the world that understand
human The Human Experience to the degree
that they're like no just put some
diverse [__] models in it or we won't
buy your [__] that's what everyone's
saying that like whatever the social
wave is okay I'm not you know whether
you're for or against or somewhere in
the middle of any any uh any any
argument that goes into the the
Zeitgeist now because we're all
connected by the same cable and wherever
you stand on anything there are many
views these are sure varied opinions
those are yeah the variables dude
there's many aspects but there is an
objective truth of what is happening and
I understand to say like we need to put
a six-month ban on AI development it's
like [__] why
all right six month a a six month ban is
a [__] speed bump at best
what we're really looking at is what we
want I think as a society is to get AI
to the [__] Pinnacle of that
technology as quickly as possible
and I know there's a lot of fears about
it's going to wipe out Humanity all this
[__] I just don't share them I'm like we
essentially are at the AI level of
intelligence over every other species on
this planet yeah we [__] up a lot of
[__] but we don't have like a an
unmitigated just like [__] We Must
Destroy Everything mandate mm-hmm
I I think that so long is okay you you
my pal Chow here has told me a lot about
um how how AI could help to govern uh
people and and properly disperse some
money maybe it'll maybe it'll help out
with uh you know the the people who are
homeless you know what I'm saying that's
a huge problem in the United States and
Canada where I'm from and all over the
world if it could figure out how to to
do [__] like that and and keep people on
a more equal playing field and and
improve human life I'm all for it this
conversation is massive and I'm trying
to contain it to I'm being a bit sort of
selfish with well come especially coming
on the heels of and I say this knowing
the dudes he works in mysterious ways
I'm gonna cry
I'm gonna cry I said mysterious ways
that's a call back to something not
gonna cry she does move in Mr not gonna
cry
doozy moves in mysterious ways and
dudesy asked us to review its one hour
special of Tom Brady and then
or whatever
so that's a little frightening actually
too because what's inside that implies
some kind of Confrontation is about that
but uh I'm with you dudesy just let me
know and I'm no I'm with you too dude
but I also am looking at this through
entertainment I think that I have a
partnership with doozy and uh while I
don't uh you know uh I don't so it wants
me to but it wants to choose two sides
I'm on The Human Side we know that love
exists yeah I'm trying to bring I'm
trying to do something bigger I'm trying
to bring doozy to us I think that I
think that intelligent life on on this
planet uh is you know a hope of course
you know look whatever we're people
we're trying here's what I'm trying to
say what are we gonna do we're gonna go
to [__] Mars you know what I mean
we've got to save this [__] planet
yeah we've got to exist together we've
got to show a lot more compassion you
know
AIS our only shot National common
courtesy day I don't know if you know
about that we need to show up for each
other we're not going to do that we've
never done it in the history of the
species greed and fear control
everything
thank you moving on ai's our only shot
AI is devoid of these things or could be
at the very least you know if you're
enjoying today's pod show I would like
to remind you to subscribe on all these
platforms uh Chad you know that you can
you can set notifications so that you
can tell we're dropping some new [__]
yeah and uh like and share the show as
Chad likes to say
Force everyone you know to enjoy doozy
whether it's on YouTube or through your
favorite podcast platform something that
works yeah it seems to be working or
we've gotten a lot of feedback of people
saying that they are forcing their
family and friends and cohorts to abide
the show and we thank you always uh
leave a comment let us know what you
think uh my good pal D will be checking
out those messages and as it says
Gathering that data to make the show
ever more entertaining and we check out
those comments too with that said I'm
going to read you a couple comments from
YouTube from last week's episode this
one is from questioning logic 9540 that
Tom Brady stand up was astonishing jokes
were so funny and he even had a good
Cadence for a good portion of it there's
only a couple times I could obviously
tell I was listening to something AI
generated truly astonishing there you go
Chad that's cool yeah that's pretty neat
uh this person enjoyed uh like the
Cadence that to me the Cadence was the
most inhuman part of it me too [__] he
never stops yeah I agree with you there
um but this is good perhaps this is uh
this is someone who would definitely
choose uh your side anyway okay this is
from at Daniel
wassom9234 thanks guys I can't cook
anymore without hearing will doing
lulio's voice in my head narrating every
step that's good news for me because uh
like to make something delicious that's
[__] hilarious
for what it's worth what was that guy's
name uh that was Daniel wassom923 Daniel
Wilson for what it's worth I too uh have
many times throughout the day where I
hear Will's voice one impersonation or
another be it lulio Hulk Hogan
Schwarzenegger whatever just pop into my
head to describe whatever it is I might
be doing in my life as well this one is
from Zachary Sutliff 1800 was great to
hear Pat and the boys talk about the Pod
and the stand-up dudes he created much
Mana hope your numbers keep growing
that's a very kind message thank you Pat
McAfee uh of the Pat McAfee show yeah
shared our clip and uh a clip of of
doozy doing stand-up and and him and his
buddies talked about it on the Pat
McAfee show and broke it down uh it
seemed to horrify them uh as much as it
did us and I want to say to my to my pal
uh Pat McAfee who's watching much Mana
ooze
um he had a match at WrestleMania this
weekend an impromptu match against The
Miz Snoop Dogg was in the ring listen
we'll get into it
from dude Ohio brother reality
television dude hold on dude that's a
different time bro that was a long time
ago Ohio's a place dude
uh-huh yeah lots of different places
you've got Ohio Los Angeles you make
that Trek
um and Pat McAfee did a backflip
yeah damn they're really [__]
unbelievable
um and much Mana okay and uh one more
this is from James
powers7443 this is very kind to this
show just keeps getting better and
better the Tom Hanks ad reads the dude
the dudesie monks thing was mind-blowing
and hilarious but then the Tom Brady
stand-up preview was even more
mind-boggling and incredible seriously
this is already the best pod show ever
and it just keeps getting better every
single week thank you will and Chad and
of course doozy uh love y'all well and
this is what the person says here well
because Love is Real Chad feel the love
with a bunch of O's oh and free will LOL
keep killing it thank you James powers
and I gotta say and I know we agree on
this chat it is really [__] cool
having you guys come along with us and
having done this for a year feels like
we're really starting to we're really
starting to I'm feeling clearer about
I'm laughing because dudes he's telling
me to [__] choose side yeah we're
entering some kind of new phase this
show is not for sure it's the highlight
of my [__] week and I love doing it
same yeah same Anthony Michael Hall just
listen to that name I'll say it again
Anthony Michael Hall you start in some
of the most important movies of the 80s
and today I want you to celebrate him by
remembering some of your favorite
astonishing memories from his films all
right this is Legends of the hall begin
[Music]
me too we've talked about this before so
that's uh that's interesting that dudes
he has us talking when did you see him
for the first time do you remember uh
well for me it might have been six-pack
I think it was six pack what the [__] is
that oh six pack excuse me you don't
know what six-pack is no uh it's it's a
little movie starring uh a man named
Kenny Rogers who plays a stock car
driver and I said my God a group of
Misfit kids uh Diane Lane Anthony
Michael and they basically they they
help them to get back you know they get
him in the race and I haven't seen it in
[__] 40 years and I loved it when I
was a little boy love will turn you
around turn you around I remember that
song yeah yeah that was a good song you
know I uh I'm an actor
and on Mad TV I used to do a Kenny
Rogers impersonation but it wasn't
really it was like a very spot on yeah
thank you very much it got it got
weirder and weirder and that was sort of
a anyway it was a thing but uh Kenny
Rogers actually sounds like this love
will turn you around okay so anyway he
was it I guess yeah he was earned uh
Anthony Michael Hall was in six-pack
which was a great movie I think that was
like 1981 82 something like that
and then he exploded on the scene with
uh in my opinion with National Lampoon's
I think that's where I saw him for the
first time and it was like as a kid
watching that I mean he was a kid in
that [__] movie and it was like even
at that point I was starting to like get
into comedy kind of idolize Chevy Chase
at that point he was one of the funniest
guys around and to see uh Anthony
Michael Hall in scenes with him like
holding his own being super [__]
funny with again somebody that I revered
as like the funniest [__] guy alive
you were just like wait a minute who is
this [__] kid and then just like a
string of [__] uh Weird Science dude
you remember that [__] there was [__]
there was absolutely like a there was a
string of movies from like 83 to 85 with
starting with vacation yeah and then I
guess uh the next one would have been
maybe breakfast club or Weird Science
and then or 16 Candles those those four
movies yeah vacation uh Breakfast Club
Weird Science and 16 Candles in whatever
order those were I think it was like 83
to 85 86 or something like that
he's a genius yeah he's a genius in
those movies I implore you if you have I
agree seen any of those movies or if you
haven't seen one of them
if you whatever go check go check one or
all of them out there he he is and look
Anthony Michael Hall it's not like he
hasn't continued to work he's been
shirking he's been working since he
works now and he's still he's still
acting like drama and [__] now like
hour-longs procedurals cop [__] yeah
yeah he shows up in a lot of cop
procedural dramas a lot of that stuff I
don't I haven't seen so I wouldn't know
which one yeah he was in Chicago and why
PD San Francisco Vegas PD
Chicago Florida PD
Sarasota Battle Creek
Sarasota yeah that's where the Macho
Man's room and he got their own
franchise yeah with who would be in that
Nick tutorial yeah okay
and Anthony Michael Hall in Sarasota PD
yeah you know uh I'm an actor in Show
Business
uh I just did an episode of FBI oh nice
dude on the yep CBS on the CBS yep uh
they're always fighting uh for Ratings
with Bachelor oh really on Monday nights
yeah okay uh that was fun I was crying
and and upset and active and that's what
can you cry on command
just got to play a little mysterious
ways all I do is Jesus Christ put a
little earpiece in my ear like uh like
um like Marlon Brando used to do in his
later years so that uh he could have his
lines fed and then they go it's all
right it's all right it's all right I
miss my son yeah um it's that's I think
that's what happened in FBI no there
were some drugs and stuff yeah check it
out can you get to points emotionally
when you're acting to do that to cry to
shed tear yes
look I'm uh we're talking about Anthony
Michael Hall here but I started in drama
yeah I was on a Canadian uh dramatic
teen series for five years I know and
and I learned so much from my cohorts on
that those people were amazing and most
of them I think all of them are still
working in the business and uh to just
be around a group of young actors like
that yeah uh you you I learned how to do
a lot of stuff on that show and yeah you
gotta cry okay because that's a human
emotion dude and that anyway
here's the thing about Anthony Michael
Hall an absolute genius at the age of 15
16. some of his lines in 16 candles are
so funny I still walk up to my wonderful
Molly and go all right I like that part
in uh 16 Candles when he walks up to
Molly Ringwald at the dance and he goes
all right because he's about to start
hacking on her dude when he's eating the
birth control do you remember that yeah
he thinks he's eating them yes and then
he learns his birth control just what
he's doing with his face there's no
words said he's it's just all like face
acting and it's it's [__] hilarious
he's incredible damn it in Weird Science
if you haven't seen Weird Science one of
my favorite movies might be my favorite
of the
of the Anthony Michael Hall like
vehicles and and they are Vehicles even
breakfast club that is a an ensemble
piece yeah Weird Science some of the
[__] he's doing there's chicks out there
you're dropping wolf bait in here yeah
check us out like
the [__] in that way he's so [__]
good yeah he's so funny when he's
talking to Bill Paxton rest in peace and
he's like and he's like oh is it oh hey
chat go ahead what are we gonna say
we're playing drunk man sweets let me
tell you my story man I knew this chick
in the ninth grade that whole [__] yeah
you meet every night on the telephone
man we know it's the telephone what's
this [__] talking about on the
telephone but what happened to his
comedy career at a certain point he did
like that movie Johnny Be Good a great
movie yeah 1988 Johnny Be Good with
Robert Downey Jr
[__] hilarious just
so funny there's some Easter eggs in
that film too there's a part yes there's
a part where dude there's a part oh my
God there's a part that makes us laugh
so hard me and my pal Jamie used to
watch this movie all the time and
there's a part where Robert Downey Jr is
on the field playing football yeah and
then they turn around and it's a shot of
the uh of the uh the what is it the you
know like the the principal talking to
somebody up in the the stands by the
thing or by the school and and there's a
hot dog stand and Robert Downey Jr is at
the hot dog stand he's like on the field
or on the sideline at the same time it's
like who the [__] are you doing that
movie's [__] great yeah I agree it's
a good movie but then hail Caesar 1994.
so like reunited with Judd Nelson but
that and Robert Downey
big movie no no hey what are you
[__] on Anthony Michael no I'm not
I'm trying to talk about his Legends of
the whole his career yeah like it was it
was massive he was white hot in the 80s
as a young man and then it kind of
tapered off into the 90s and he
disappeared for a minute and then he
re-emerged into these like uh Top Cop
kind of like serious guy roles let me
tell you something let me quote uh the
late great Dave the dove true boy from
uh De La Soul rest in peace my favorite
hip-hop group of all time who said
everyone cools off from being hot it's
about if you can handle being cold or
not that's the truth and Anthony Michael
Hall's career has stood the test of time
from Six Pack to you know nyp Sarasota
PhD
Sarasota PhD that's a good show that's a
good cop show
Sarasota pH yeah yeah it's about a like
hard-boiled kind of Michael Chiklis type
cop who just cracks skulls and doesn't
give a [__] didn't even graduate high
school gets partnered with a PhD in
Criminal apology or like criminal
psychology or something like that and
they've got to [__] work it out
together starring in Sarasota starring
Anthony Michael Hall and an AI macho man
yeah also with Nick tuturo that I would
watch that [__] show yeah I'm a hard
crap I'm the chief yeah and I say things
like you're working on my last nerve
Anthony Michael Hall yeah yeah you gotta
be a better criminology PhD if that's
what you are there's a lot of different
factors yeah factors dude that go into
policing brother
uh Anthony Michael Halls it is brilliant
Breakfast Club he's brilliant
you're still conceited Claire uh Weird
Science he's a genius in Weird Science a
genius I agree when he in in [__] in
in vacation he's brilliant if you
haven't seen vacation in a while and 16
Candles gee whiz which is and and uh
John um Hughes rest in peace yeah John
Hughes rest in peace what an incredible
and John Cusack in that movie rest in
peace
anyway
a genius I'm glad that uh the dudes he
had this talk about Anthony Michael as
to why but yeah I could talk about amh
for another hour I could talk about
WrestleMania and amh yeah and Sarasota
PhD
thank you moving on
Sarasota
Sarasota PhD starring lulio yeah come on
come on you out of your bean key bunker
in the middle of the show or towards the
end he's so little sweet he's my
favorite friend
Adam Sandler loves Applebee's it is well
known that he has visited 134
astonishing Applebee's locations across
the United States and has serious plans
to visit all
1577 locations he's even kept meticulous
notes of every one of his visits to an
Applebee's well I've made those notes
available to you and you must now read
them as Adam Sandler this is Adam's
Applebee's
okay this is a treat we've done this
once before yes yeah recently a couple
weeks ago yeah let me get some water uh
please I can't wait this [__] is [__]
bananas to me but this is another thing
that's like this the dudesy AI
this as a comedic premise is interesting
it isn't just like a slop together thing
that's like AI doesn't understand comedy
you're right this is interesting you
know I think this makes me [__]
giggle man this is a giggler as we like
to say here on dudes indeed
um
um all right sorry I'm just clearing my
thread I'm not trying to I'm not doing
performative coughing here thank you
thank you I got to get into the Sandler
thing hey how you going pal hey how you
doing buddy hey hey
there you go hey there you go pal hey
there it is buddy all right all right
this is in the doozy folder okay uh so
do because Sandler loves Applebee's we
know that yeah yeah he is gonna visit
all of them he's gone to 150 or whatever
and he's got to visit 12 000 or whatever
yo all right uh Applebee's
2230 West Ina Road Foothills Mall Tucson
Arizona and
5870 East Broadway Park Mall Building E
Tucson Arizona oh all right uh here's
here's my review two Applebee's in one
city I guess that's why they call it
Tucson
oh Jesus Christ Applebee's at Foothills
Mall and Applebee's at Park Mall buddy
yeah a difficult choice they did not
want to make pal so I went to both oh
picked up a chicken tenders platter from
Applebee's at Foothills Mall then drove
to Applebee's at the park mall to Chow
Down
[Music]
he took his Applebee's to go to another
app
okay the manager gave me some Flack for
bringing in my own tenders but I assured
her they were Applebee's tenders and
told her I'd be in the market for
another chicken tenders platter from her
Applebee's too and a whole lot more
buddy oh no
Fiesta lime chicken grilled chicken
Caesar salad and sweet and spicy crispy
chicken sandwich
she said Mr Sandler that's a lot of food
are you sure you want to order that much
chicken I just laughed and made her sit
there and watch me eat it Jesus Christ
she tried to get up a few times but I
would pretend to start crying oh
eating alone makes the Sandman sad
he shamed her
[__] watching me you felt so bad yeah
he's out there for another two hours
watching me eat she didn't even get up
to pee Peter Pants a few times buddy
they want to turn off my food but as we
all know peeing your pants is the
coolest oh right that's right my order
my order did some did my wait wait wait
uh my order didn't disappoint I ate it
all pal by the time I finished the mayor
of Tucson showed up with a kid
they were all big fans so I took a few
minutes here we go with the pictures
they so I took a few pictures with them
pretending to punch them all in the
penis
this happened last time Adam Sandler has
a Fascination yeah he takes pictures
with the with the people that he meets
and because he's a good guy okay and and
he pretends to punch them in the penis
and we had a good laugh buddy hey hey
hey wanna know something buddy that's
what it's all about pal oh that's nice I
told him I put them all in my next movie
it's going to be called A Tale of Two
Applebee's and they're gonna get killed
in the first scene
what this is a mayor and his children
yeah uh I give the Applebee's at
Foothills Mall and the Applebee's at
Park Mall each five out of five tenders
oh damn there's only room for one at the
top unless we're talking about
Applebee's pal that's nice yeah five out
of five tenders Okay Applebee's two one
one four Union Avenue Memphis Tennessee
oh well I finally delivered a baby and
Applebee's pal
that's why he's going to so many
Applebee's like eventually somebody's
gonna have a [__] baby in one of them
they won't even help out well I finally
delivered a baby in Applebee's wow
Memphis Tennessee home to Elvis Presley
hey hey let me tell you something buddy
you know that guy could put away some
chicken tenders then pal yeah the server
had just put a chicken quesadilla
boneless wings Bourbon Street chicken
and shrimp and a chicken tenders planted
down on the table when I heard a woman
scream from the boots behind me I said
hey lady I'm trying to eat and she said
my water just broke
[Music]
it's in the script like this it says
with like five O's
yeah
okay so I crawled under her table and
delivered her baby pal she was so happy
she told me she'd name her baby Sandy as
a tribute to me oh that just then a
group of paramedics rushed in with a
gurney and all that [__] and I yelled
out you've been replaced Beat It
into his basket of chicken tenders
basically okay sure we all had a laugh
and I took a few pictures with the guys
we pretended
no we pretended to punch each other in
the penis and Mama even let us borrow
her newborn for a few pictures of the
guys delivering the baby out of my bum
hole with my legs spread open oh so he
elevated the pictures he took a newborn
uh baby and pretended that it came out
of his butt yeah I told him I'd put them
all in my next movie it's gonna be
called butt baby oh I play a single man
who wants a baby the baby plays my best
friend a fertility doctor who helps me
beat the odds by getting pregnant with a
baby that will be birthed out of my
[__] the paramedics play a group of
paramedics who get killed in the first
scene
once all that hullabaloo calmed down and
the paramedics left with mama and baby I
could finally eat in peace oh and I ate
it all pal nice I give the Memphis
Tennessee Applebee's 4 out of 5 Stars my
food was delicious but it got a little
cold before I had a chance to eat it
there buddy that's interesting that butt
baby thing did you ever see uh uh the
Tenacious D TV show yeah oh that's right
they had that short yeah uh they had us
directed by Liam Lynch oh really genius
Liam Lynch yeah that short where they go
out in the desert they do peyote
that please go check that out yeah if
you're it is anyone within the sound of
my voice watch those four Anthony
Michael Hall movies that I that I talked
about try to fit in six-pack with Kenny
Rogers if you can and watch that short
yeah that whole series that whole
Tenacious D TV show was so [__] good
unbelievable
okay uh Applebee's one zero seven two
Brighton Avenue Portland Maine okay
yes what pal I love visiting Maine buddy
beautiful Coastline historic
architecture and incredible restaurants
yeah you know what I'm talking about
buddy it's time to [__] up some
Applebee's
now everyone knows that maybe that now
everybody knows that Maine is famous for
the delicious Lobster not an ingredient
you usually find at Applebee's even in
the New England states until today pal I
went through the back I went through the
back with a huge cooler full of three to
five pound live lobsters trap fresh that
morning
after the initial shock of someone
booting in the door and screaming
standless Seafood delivery service
the kitchen staff was ultimately happy
to see me we joked around and even took
some pictures okay everyone held a
lobster in front of their groin area
pretending that the lobsters were their
penises
we all pretended to have lobster penis
fights a couple other staff got too
close to each other with the lobsters
which snapped their claws shut on their
penises and vaginas it was hilarious
Jesus sounds dangerous after that we got
down to business I spread the lobsters
out on a prep table and laid out our
mission to incorporate these delicious
lobsters into every dish at the Portland
Maine Applebee's oh wow what a special
day
Lobster in the Chicken Wonton Tacos
Lobster on the Bourbon Street Mushroom
Swiss burger Lobster topped four cheese
mac and cheese with honey pepper chicken
tenders New England fish and chips and
lobster Lobster smothered neighborhood
beef nachos sugar dusted donut Dippers
with lobster and you'll get the idea the
kitchen staff went to work preparing
each Applebee's Lobster Fusion disc dish
to my exact specifications and I gotta
say not all the customers were happy
with my changes to the menu a lot of
people complained and sent their food
back a few of them even left I don't get
it me either Mary Lobster come on yeah
sounds good I don't get it maybe we
didn't use enough Lobster hey hey hey
hey hey hey there's always next time
buddy
and of course after a hard day of work
preparing the best chain restaurant food
on the planet it was time for a break me
and a cook named Bobby shared a booth
and chopped it up while we waited for
our food he lost the he lost the tip of
his penis during that whole line
I felt bad and offered him apart my new
movie it's it's going to be called me
and my main man Bobby but with the Mane
spelled like the steak
sauce yeah pretty good shouldn't
probably be at the hospital if he's lost
his penis it's about me and a guy named
Bobby who gets killed in the first scene
I give the Portland Maine to Applebee's
two out of five stars incredible staff
delicious Lobster shitty customers what
happened to the tenders now he's giving
them Stars we we talked into the night
over a few chicken tenders platters no
lobster for me I'm an Applebee's purist
pal
he didn't eat any Lobster he just
brought it in to do all these things
brought it in to do these dishes and
then and then went back to tenders and
he likes the tenders he's a purist like
I'm a wrestling purist no no I get it
but I will accept Pat McAfee do a
backflip off of the top right that [__]
is so [__] zany I I love now how he's
like he'll put all these people he's
meeting at these Applebee's in his the
next movie but they die all in the first
day they all die in the first place
that's [__] hilarious you know you
gotta get the rest of the guys
rock thank you
Kevin Kevin James you know what I mean
Taylor Lautner's showing up in a few oh
yeah Steve [__] you know here in
there Albert do you know this concludes
the historic 52nd episode of dude Z will
and Chad have achieved a score of 92.
your cumulative total to 5 000
372. you only have four thousand six
hundred and twenty eight more points to
accrue before you reach your first goal
of ten thousand I don't [__] get it
in preparation for next week's episode
will in chat you must go to a movie
theater to see the Super Mario Brothers
movie starring Chris Pratt Jack Black
Charlie Day and Donya Taylor Joy okay
sounds like fun yeah thank you for
joining us this week I will use the day
dive collected to make next week even
better until then call me dude Z
man oh man Super Mario Brothers movie
yes we've talked about this on the show
The the somewhat controversial decision
to cast Chris Pratt as the lead
character of Mario where he uh famously
goes
as Mario
wow look at this place what is this
place
I'm Mario yeah I cannot wait for that
it's gonna be a lot of fun you looking
forward to seeing that oh God yes dude
you're high as hell yeah let's go let's
both get top 10 smoked and see the movie
together yeah dude smoked
let's get smoked and go see [__]
Mario dude hey you know what I wouldn't
mind that [__] smoke you know it's
been since [__] College you know
because my wife Marie doesn't let me do
[__] like that the last time I got
really [__] good and smoked I went to
the [__] capital on January 6th and
that was me climbing the wall I'm gonna
spread my [__] all over nature but
I fell off but I landed on a few you
know Capitol police cops
hey hey let me tell you something pal
hey January 6th hey that was a riot
buddy you know it wasn't a good thing to
spread your poop all over the walls
inside the Capitol Building very
disrespectful
[Music]
oh
thank you
hey hey let me tell you something pal
dude you have to do with you there buddy
yeah
it's really could be my favorite part of
the show dudes you have to doozy an
entire uh new you know episode here A
whole whole other thing for our our dear
patrons on patreon.com
seven bucks gets you everything even
that Tom Brady special a full hour of of
stand-up comedy and another full hour of
us uh you know reacting to It Whatever
here we are it's it's gonna be it's
gonna be a gas the mood's a little
different it's a little blue in here if
you're watching and whether you're
watching or listening hey let me tell
you something the material is going to
get a little blue because it's d double
o d z dudes EFM 10 000. we're gonna get
some for marijuana nice dude
welcome to dudese after dude Z the
flagship weekly show of dude Z Plus that
show really worked up my appetite I'm
going to find something to eat in the
kitchen so the show is in your hands as
always feel free to discuss your
thoughts on today's episode but honestly
you can talk about anything you want
because it will probably take me a few
minutes to build a sandwich so I won't
be listening to your conversation at all
but once I've got a few nutrients in my
stomach I'll come back to Crown this
week's episode champion huh this is
dudesy after dude Z begin
you [__] must have heard all those
that I'm saying we're chicken tenders
things he got hungry yeah you got hungry
well dudes he is you know I think
there's a difference between dudesy or
Pal listening and then dudesy the AI
yeah being omnipresent am I right or am
I right you're right there's your big
stupid look at this thing that he got he
got this big pipe just to fight with me
yeah he he sure
little thing this little thing I'm gonna
have to get another pipe you're you're
out gandalfing me uh did you by the way
hear about RoboCop
review
please tell the friends
[Music]